[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مره بكثير من العقبات والعوائق
التي اعترضت طريقه تنصيبه مديرا عاما
لمعهد العالم العربي في باريس وهو خريج
الدراسات العليا من جامعه السربون في
فرنسا والاستاذ الزائر فيها والاستاذ في
جامعه الملك سعود وفي جامعه اليمامه وهو
الناقد الروائي الذي كتب مكتب عرسين يرمي
من ورائه الى تدوين تجربته ومسيرته في
المعهد خلال الفتره التي قضاها في ادارته
وشخصيه استطاعت ان تضع ايضا لها بصمه
معروفه ناقد والكاتب والمدير السابق لمعهد
العالم العربي في باريس واستاذي انا ايضا
الدكتور المعجم الزهراني في سؤال حياك
الله دكتور
سعيد بتواجدك معي وانا كنت احد ابنائك
وطلابك في جامعه الملك سعود اليوم تسمح لي
انا من يدير هذا المكان يعني انا اسعدت ما
كنت عليه فعلا لان هذه قريبه جدا مهنه
الفلاح مثمره
في وقت لاحق اشكرك دكتور 2016 الى 2022
هذا التاريخ خلال ست سنوات كنت فيه مديرا
لمعهد العالم العربي في باريس تجربه مليئه
بالكثير بتحديات والعقبات ويمكن كتبت انت
عنها ايضا في مكتب على السي لكن انا بسالك
وانت قلت بانه تعيني لم يكن امرا سهلا
ابدا المساله مرت باكثر من سنه في
بمفاوضات ولولا الدكتور خالد العنقر يعني
ذاك الذي كان سفير المملكه في باريس يمكن
ما كنت تعينت يعني لماذا كان او استغرق كل
هذا الوقت مساله المفاوضات لتعيين مدير
معهد العالم العربي في باريس
اولا يا عزيزي هي كانت
تجربه بالنسبه لي انا اعشق باريس وعشت
فيها اكثر من عشت في قريتي وبالتالي حينما
تقاعدت ثم من جامعه اليمامه اربع سنوات
وعرض علي
الموقع او المنصب شعرت بانني محظوظ يعني
وبالتالي
ذهبت بنوع من انواع الحماس ولكن ارهانات
رهانات محدده لان الفرص وهذا ما ذكرته
عليه باستمرار الفرصه ليست سعيده او شقيه
الا بحسب ما تحولها انت الى رهان وتحاول
ان تكسره وبالتالي سافرت
في ذهني انه انا اعرف شكل رئيس المعهد من
فتره طويله وذكرت التفاصيل هذه المعرفه
وكنت اتوقع انه الموضوع الي او بشكل او
باخر يعني سهل جدا
وحينما
التقيتم مره مره اخرى ادركت ادركت انه كان
يخفي غير غير ما يظهر لانه المملكه
للامانه اخذت
حصتها من المنصب مع الاستاذ منى زندار
بقيه سنه او فتره ونصف يعني حوالي اربع
سنوات ونص وبالتالي المملكه كانت قانونيا
ليس ليس مع ليس لها سوى سنه ونصف
انا راح انت على انه سنه ونص لا يمكن نقبل
المنصب واتفقنا على ثلاث سنوات لكن اكتشفت
انه حتى هذا التنازل لم يكن
لم يكن مقنعا له وبالتالي شعرت انه يلعب
لعبه معينه لعبه مكر فقلت لابد ان ناتي من
فوق يعني لابد يكون في مكر وبدات اكشف
الاوراق للسفر وش كان منطقة دكتور كان في
اعتقادي انه كان لدي مرشح عربي اخر وانه
كان فيه وعد من الملك عبد الله رحمه الله
بمبلغ معين دعم المعهد قبل قبلي وقبل اظن
المناخه زندار حتى وكان يريد ان يحصل عليه
ويقول انتم قانونيين اخذتم حصتكم وانتهى
الموضوع
فحينما عرضت الموضوع على
المعادن الاستاذ خالد العنقري وهو
يعني من هو في الخبره والتجربه ولكن ايضا
كان في نوع من انواع العلاقه الحميمه لا
اقول الصداقه لكن علاقه حميمه بيني وبينه
من فتره معينه
فيبدو انه حسمها بطريقه
جيده
وغريب جدا انه بعد ما مره ثلاث سنوات اصر
جاك لاند قبل غيره على ان يمدد لي
وفي الفتره الثانيه قبيل سفري باسابيع
وبيوم واحد كان يرسل لي كل مره شخص لكي
امدد الفتره الثالثه يعني كان بامكاني ان
اقضي تسع سنوات في المعهد لماذا اظنه
اكتشف ان
هذا المرشح الذي لم يكن مرضيا عنه في
البدايه عمل شيئا نوعيه للمعهد هذا ما
ارجوه علي الحاله هي المساله انه عمل شيء
ولا على انه الدعم حيستمر لم لم تتبرع
المملكه بعدها باي شيء من بعد ما من بعد
الخمسه مليون لم يكن هناك اي اي الفتره
الاولى الفتره الاولى من ايام الملك عبد
الله لكن ايضا كان عندنا معرض العلا وكان
في بعض التعاون لكن اعتقد انه
بحسن الحظ والفض شركات
مثمره بناءه جاده مع جيلك فيصل في الرياض
مع محمد شحرور
اظنني استطعت ان
اقدم شيء نوعي للمعهد وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بجنوب المتوسط بالشركه العربي وجاك
للامانه ورجل سياسي من الطراز الاول لكن
استاذ جامعي ومثقف كبير وبالتالي ادرك ان
ان هناك شيء جديد
ربما يتطور وانا لو لو بقيت
وكان عندي دعم بالتاكيد سيحضر المعهد في
العالم العربي اكثر واكثر لكن انا وصلت
الى مرحله التشبع جمالي من باريس
وتشبع من المعهد وفي لحظه من اللحظات انا
اعتقد الانسان الذي يتمتع بقدر من الحكمه
انه اذا لم يعد لديه اضافات نوعيه عليه ان
ينسحبه وهو في الذره والا والا يصبح مثل
زعماء العالم الثالث يظل الواحد الى ان
يخرب كل ما بناته والحياه طيب بدات ماك
رحله التحديات في المعهد يمكن من اول يوم
دخلت فيه دكتور معجم اذا رجعنا الى هذا
اليوم انت تقول ايضا في الكتاب انه نسبه
قليله من العاملين
لديهم روح التعاون الاغلبيه كانوا متوجي
وربما بعضهم حتى لا يريدك قلت تحدثت عن
حادثه
هناك من كتبت مقال في صحيفه فرنسيه
الشهيره ضد المرشح السعودي عندما علمت بان
من سيدير المعهد هو سعودي الجنسيه وقالت
بان ذلك كان مثل الصفا على وجههم للدرجه
هذه دكتور هذه
في مقابله عابره سريعه مع
[موسيقى]
ذكرت لها اسمه قبل قليل اللبنانيه
الفرنسيه وكان لها معرض في المعهد
اول ما وصلت شاركت في الافتتاح لكن لم
اقابلها فقالت لمراسل الجاردين انه حينما
سمعت بالخبر كما لو كان صفحه
فيه في جانبي للقضيه في جانب ما يسمى
بالصوره النمطيه والافكار المسبقه
كانت تلعب دور كبير جدا حتى داخل المعهد
انه هذا انسان سعودي جاء وليس لديه اضافه
معينه وربما انه كان واحد عربي من المغرب
او من بلاد الشام هو الاولى وكذا وكذا لكن
الجانب الثاني ان هناك اصدقاء كثر وزملاء
كثر في الوسط الثقافي الباريسي يعرفوني
جيدا من ايام الدراسه ومنهم ثلاثه واربعه
في المعهد هؤلاء كانهم موقف اخر ربما
شعروا بنوع من السعاده نوع من العداله نوع
من الانصاف انه يكون فيه اكاديمي يعرفون
جيدا في المعهد
الذي
تيقنت منه
ان ان هذه الصور النمطيه لم تكن تؤثر علي
باي شكل من الاشكال لانني كنت واعيا
بشيء بسيط واضح وهو ان الانجاز هو الذي
سيحكم في النهايه ومن هنا بدات
وسايره واجامل
واستوعب الى الى ان
عملت ما استطيع ان عمله واعتقد اعتقد انه
في النهايات
ليس بده ان نخوض في التفاصيل لكن كان هناك
كسبت الرهان بطريقه انسانيه وهذا الذي
يهمني ليس فقط بالانجاز الذي فعلت وانما
على مستوى العلاقه
عزيزي انا منذ ان وصلت المعهد استفدت من
كل شيء غاز القصيب الثقافي الذي انشاته في
جامعه اليمامه
فانشات كرسي ما حد الثقافي وذلك لهدف محدد
ولا يخلو من المكر للامانه انه المعهد تحت
اداره
اشراف قانوني من وزاره الخارجيه
شخصيه
رسميه
معروفه جيدا يعني يكاد يكون نجم بالمعنى
العالمي بالمعنى المعروف العالم كله
فانا اكاديبي
ماذا يمكن ان اعمل في مثل هذه الظروف قلت
لابد ان اراهن على ما اتقنه على ما يحسنه
وسيرتي كلها اكاديميه فبالتالي هذا
الكرسي عانى وجه بعض الصعوبات لكن كنت
مدير عام لم يعني لم يكن يعترض فبالتالي
اعلنت عن كرسي وبدات اضع له برامج محدده
انشطه ثقافيه من النوع
الجد والعالي مع كبار باحثين ومفكرين من
داخل فرنسا ومن خارجها وبعد فتره استحدثنا
تكريم شخصيه من الوزن الثقيل من النجوم
وبداناها بواحد اظن اشهر اشهر فيلسوف في
فرنسا ثانوي وترجمه عن طريق الثقافيه
السعوديه ومعروف
ثم العروي ثم هشام جعيط
ورشدي راشد واندري ميكيل وفلان يعني من
الاسماء الوازنه جدا
وايضا كان لدينا منذ البدايه
الامور تتضح لدى غالبيه الناس الذين كانوا
مناوين ربما استثني بعض الاسماء لكن زي
مثلا الطاهر بن جلول لديه موقف مرضي من من
الثمانينات تعرفه يعني الخليج عنده لا
يوجد يعني عنده عنصريه مقلوبه ولم يكن
يعني وحتى لم نكتب
ليست شائعه لكن هذا من نماذج العليا مثل
مثل اللبنانيه اندري
شديد
عدنان يعني لديهم نوع من انواع العنصريه
المقلوبه من الامانه لاحقا اتصلت علي اكثر
من مره وراسلتني اكثر مره ودعتني اكثر مره
لبيتها وتعتذر قلت لها المكتب مكتبك متى
احببتي لكني لن اتى
يعني نوع من انواع
ضع نفسك حيث تريد ان يضعك الناس تصل قصير
مشاهدين ونعود اليكم في سؤال مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفي هو
الناقد والكاتب ومدير معهد العالم العربي
في باريس سابقا الدكتور معجب الزهراني
حياك الله دكتور مرحبا من يعطي امر 60% من
الدعم للمعهد من وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
40% للدول العربيه الاخرى
هذا هل هذا يعني بانه من يتحكم في
الفعاليات والمعارض وندوات وكل ما يختص
بالشان الثقافي والفني
هي
السلطات الفرنسيه والخارجيه الفرنسيه
تحديدا لا تصحيح المعلومه كان كان الاتفاق
في البدايه انه خمسين في الميه خمسين في
الميه يعني شراكه كامله
لاحقا تلكات الكثير من الدول العربيه
وخاصه كما ذكرت في في
مكتب على السن الدول الجمهوريه التقدميه
الاشتراكيه
تنكات كثيرا واصبح المعاد في ازمه فاتفق
على انه اربعين في المئه من الجانب العربي
هو 60% من الجانب
اهل الفرنسي وبعد هذا حصل تنصت الدول
العربيه كلها من الالتزام كل شيء رسمي
لماذا لانه كان في اجتهاد من احد المدراء
المعاهد انه اعطونا ما تبقى لديكم ونحن
سنستثمر ونستغني عن هذه المطالبات السنويه
غير المضمونه
استثمر حوالي خمسين مليون يورو لم يكن
يعمل شيئا وبالتالي الان ليس هناك دوله
عربيه تسهم بشكل منتظم في ميزانيه المعهد
فقط تابع لوزاره الخارجيه وزاره الخارجيه
مشكوره تتحمل الجزء الاكبر من ميزانه
المعهد هناك دعم وهذا شيء كما تعلم غير
غير المنتظم يعني غير رسمه
وللامانه السعوديه والامارات وبعض دول
الخليج لها الدوره الاكبر في الحفاظ على
هذه العلاقه وهذه خساره كبرى لانه كل
الدول الديمقراطيه في اوروبا لو ان
الموضوع من البدايه سلم لي
المنظمه العربيه للعلوم
والفنون او لجامعه الدول العربيه واصبحت
واصبحت الميزانيه او الحصتنا من ميزانيه
منتظمه
لربما المعهد يعني ضاعف جهده في سبيل خدمه
الثقافه العربيه رغم انه يلعب دوره حاسم
ودور مهم جدا جدا الى اليوم في
لاجمل الصور والمنتوجات الفنيه والمعرفيه
والجماليه من القديم والحديث في الفضاء
العربي لكنه كما قلت قبل قليل وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ومدخلات المعهد والا
للاسف الشديد العرب تخلوا عن هذه الجوهره
الباريسيه نعم انا اعتقد انه وليس هذا
كلامي حتى الاستاذ خالد العنقري كان يكرر
نفس الكلام ان هذا مكسب فريد من نوعه
مؤسسه فريده من نوعها في العالم اليونسكو
للعالم كله ما احد الالم العربي ينافس
اليونسكو في مبناه وموقعه وانشطته ومع ذلك
لم نتنبه له بشكل جيد وبالتالي اكرر الشكر
لبعض الدول الخليجيه التي لا تزال تعي
قيمه المعهد وتدعمه بشكل شبه منتظم دكتور
جوهر وتستضيف معرض فني بعنوان حبيبي كان
عن المثليه الجنسيه في العالم العربي
بمشاهد وصور فضائيه نتكلم فيها 2023 انت
مالك دخل في الموضوع لم تكن وقتها مديرا
للمعهد العالم العربي انا لو كنت انت مدير
دكتور هل تستطيع ايقاف هذا المعرض او عدم
عرضه اولا
المعهد لديه
362 نشاط في العام وانشطه تبدا من اهم
محاضرات وندوات الثقافيه كبرى وفكريه الى
انشطه فنيه الى المكتبه الى المتحف الى
الامسيات الموسيقيه والغنائيه الراقيه
وهذا هذا المعرض الاخير الذي لم اشارك فيه
انا ولم يكن لدي علم عنك
هذه هذه بالنسبه لي لا تشكل قشه في مهب
الريح ليس هذا
المعرض هو الذي يقيم من خلالها المعهد
وافيد بانه لو كنت مدير او الرئيس جاك
نفسه لا قد لا يستطيع ان يعترض ربما يبدي
موقف ويحتج لكنه لا يستطيع لماذا يا صديقي
لان هذا المعهد ايضا في هناك لبي او قوه
ضاغطه من هذه التيارات تختلف كثيرا من
البلد الاخر لكنها في اوروبا وفي امريكا
اصبح لها قوه ضغط ولا يستطيع احد ان
يقول انه والله هذا المعرض او هذا المعرض
يجب ان يقام لا يستطيع انت في صفحتك لا
تغرد كثير لا تعبر عن رايك
في 18/1/2023 كتبت
لو اجتهدت فلسفه لقلت فضيله الحكيم العقل
والحاكم العدل والجندي الشجاعه والفلاح
الصبر حتى تصل الى رجل الدين الصمت
لماذا تريد ان يصمت رجل الدين هو هذه هذه
مقوله فلسفيه من عهد الاستقراط وافلاطون
ان كل كل نوعيه في المجتمع كل شخص في
المجتمع له له فضيله وهي معروفه معروفه
ليست من انا فقط
بنوع من انواع المداعبه ادخلت الاخيره
لماذا لماذا قلت انه فضيله رجل الدين
الصمت انا اعتقد انه التقوى ها هنا حينما
تجد رجال الدين في مرحله معينه وعلم
امتداد العالم العربي للامانه
يصرخون ويمارسون نوع من انواع العنصر
اللفظي والعنف المادي
ويسحل الناس والشوارع في ايران وفي
باكستان في حتى في باكستان فيغستان وعندنا
هنا كلنا نعرف ماذا جرى وفي مصر اغتيالات
وفي المغرب فهذا بالنسبه لي ليس ليس هو
التدين الذي
اعرفه وعشنا عليه نحن في وقلتها اكثر من
مره اقرب ما يكون الى ما يسميه جانجا
كروسو بديل الفطره يعني تحس ان الدين كما
شبهته مثل الاكسجين نتنفسه كل يوم في
الهواء لكن لا نراه وبالتالي حينما يصمت
رجال الدين عن هذه الثرثره عن هذا الخطاب
العنيف هم يسهمون في السلم الاجتماعي
ويشكلون قدوه اددوك التبادل هددوك في فتره
من فترات طبعا كثيرين من الحقيقه لست وحدي
يعني في معرض الكتاب
اظن
في التلفزيون يكسر
الاصنام ونكسر راسك وراسل الذين يخالفون
معتقداتنا يعني تخيل هذه 1400 سنه
موجوده في في العراق وفي افغانستان وحتى
ربما في في مناطق اخرى حتى في الحجاز ربما
يكون في بقايره تماثيل معين ولم يكسر احد
وياتي هؤلاء الناس ويكسرون هذه الاعمال
الفنيه الجماليه التي كنت ادرس بعض صورها
في ماده علم الجمال ويقول انها تهدد
مقدسات الامه يعني نؤمن انواع الجنون خطاب
الجنون ولا استغرب من الخطاب الجنون يولد
مثل هذا العنف وهناك ايضا حتى في القريه
يعني لا اريد ان اخذ في التواصيل لكني
سمعت تهديدات من هذا النوع واحمد الله
انها كانت كانت
من خلال هذه الصوره مختلفه تماما انا
تابعت بالصدفه وعلى تويتر قبل ما اذهب الى
هذا الحفل
الجميل الانيق المجموعه من النساء البلد
المواطنات الشريفات الحرات في مشهد لم اكن
اتخيله انا وجيلي ذكرني بمشاهد جيل والدتي
واولئك الفلاحات
طبعا كن يعاملنا من الفجر الى المغرب
ويعمل احيانا اكثر من الرجال ولم يكن
الباحث في كل مكان زراعته في كل مكان في
كل مكان زراعي وبالتالي هذا المشهد لانه
احنا دائما نتحدث الرجال الامن والرجال
الامن اعتقد ان هناك الان مصطلح جديد اسمه
نساء الامن وسيبرز وسيدرك المتخلفون ان
المراه الحره السعوديه ستشارك في كل شيء
وليس
ولن ينجحوا في منعها من كل شيء بعد ان
قلبوها من انسانه من كائن عاقل حر مستقل
الى عار وعوره انا اعتقد ان هذه بشره خير
وسترى في المستقبل القريب ما يسرك
وبالتالي هذا المفهوم او هذا المصطلح
سيكبر هذه الشجره بدرت
ولن انسى عناق اقرباء هؤلاء النساء
وتقديمهم الورد
وقريبه وهم يحتفلون بها لاحظ معي الانقلاب
جدري في المفاهيم وارجو ان يستمر شكرا لك
الحديث معك شيق والحوار معك ايضا ضد
سجودنا نشكرك شكر جزيلا على تواجدك معنا
في سؤال المباشر هذه الحلقه شكرا لكل
المشاهدين الكرام نعتدي الحلقه من سؤال
مباشر كان ضيفي في ناقد والكاتب ومدير
معهد العالم العربي في باريس سابق الدكتور
معجب الزهراء دائما يمكنكم متابعتنا على
تويتر فيسبوك على يوتيوب ايضا ومشاهده هذه
الحلقه والاستماع اليها على شاهد وعلى
العربي
[موسيقى]